i watch this man on election nights
[Laughter]
plural truly enjoy his work and it was a
delight
yesterday to see him on football night
in america sunday night football
especially at halftime
breaking down the playoff probabilities
like it was a vote count in maricopa
county
he is none other than nbc news and msnbc
national political correspondent as he's
known on his twitter feed steve kornacki
how are you steve
rich i'm doing well how are you doing
what a pleasure to talk to you what a
pleasure to talk to you sir
um and uh was this like a
uh a dream i imagine for somebody who
does what you do for a living to to be
on uh
halftime and be part of sunday night
football has got to be
a feather in your career cap steve
honestly yeah no and thanks for having
me on here
thanks for those nice words um this was
this was a thrill
they um you know the folks at nbc sports
had um
you know got in touch with me a couple
weeks ago um
you know and i was just kind of waiting
for them to to think wiser of it and
call the whole thing off so i was i was
just thrilled that it that it actually
happened that i got the chance
you know i've been uh um you know a
football fan nfl fan really my whole
life
and um you know just the um i think the
the idea of kind of a road to the
playoffs
you know playing out the scenarios the
probabilities the what if this team
wins but this team loses i really as we
were putting it together it occurred to
me it it seemed to kind of flow very
naturally
um in a way i wasn't necessarily
expecting from
you know what i was doing with the
election and just road to 270 and
probabilities and if this candidate wins
this state but loses that state
there really did seem to be kind of an
overlap there so just i had a blast
doing it and
um really feel uh lucky i got the chance
well did
did anybody contest the results steve um
any did you get any
uh anybody demanding a recount last
night i got it
i do think some of the um there were
some vikings fans maybe who didn't like
the probability
um you know we have our partner uh pro
football focus just uh that puts the
probabilities together i think
uh despite minnesota you know moving
into that
final playoff spot in the nfc yesterday
ahead of arizona
uh the pff model still favors arizona
uh in terms of making the playoffs so i
think there might have been some uh some
folks in minnesota who didn't like that
number
so they they were looking for more of a
batch in hennepin county is that the
phrase
would that be there you go you're good
hennepin county or maybe maybe up in the
iron range
see i'm i'm feeling my oats too because
again i
i feel like i could tell you all the
counties where everybody's uh
all these all these stadiums are in
right now um
and it just uh in terms of your sports
fandom i have been told are you from
you're from mass right you're from
massachusetts correct that's right yup
grew up uh just
uh about uh 30 miles outside boston so
you steve kornacki you're a
new england patriots fan
yeah it's i've learned that's a very
polarizing thing to tell
people and i i just try to remind folks
um there was a time
the patriots weren't a dynasty and uh
they struggled to get 20
000 fans in the stadium but i was i was
a fan back then so i feel i've earned
some of the
some of the fun we've had the last two
decades so you were you were freezing
your butt off on the metal benches of
foxboro it's basically what you're
saying steve
right yeah i hey you know i was 1988
doug flutie was the quarterback for a
season
and uh it was kind of uh um a magical
time
to be a patriots fan but it was nothing
like it is right now i mean that the
brady years had to have been uh
quite something uh for for a patriot fan
to
to take all in um have you been to any
of those super bowls steve do you have
you
gone to any of those no i've never been
to the super bowl no
regular season games and watching the
super bowls but i mean yeah it
it truly truly i think everybody knows
that for the past it just came out of
nowhere i mean it was um
it went from drew bledsoe being the
quarterback of a of a 5-11 team to this
guy brady coming in one day and then
um you know two decades later it just
the winning
continued and it was um it just came
totally out of the blue and
um and it is like it's one of those
things where i have to remind people and
i think i'm getting to a certain age
here where there's there's folks who've
you know younger folks who've come up as
nfl fans not knowing anything but the
patriots being
a dynasty but um you know there was a
there was a long period there
as people my age and older know when
when that just wasn't the case
steve kornacki nbc news political
correspondent here on the rich eisen
show so uh are you going to do this
again you've got it's not a one-off i
think so yeah i mean great great
feedback last night and um i think we're
talking about you know continuing it um
next week and you know i think we'll uh
we'll you know kind of take a look and
review the uh review the game film see
where we can improve
but um i think we got some uh some good
feedback
i like that uh so what would we call you
we can't call you an nbc news political
correspondent when you're doing
this endeavor can we come up with what
you'd like what would your what would
your term for it be what would you like
to be called boy that's a good that's a
that's a good question
um what do you got you know uh
let me let me work maybe that's one of
the things we're going to have to uh
we're going to have to sit down and
and come up with here in the next couple
days you could see steve kornacki nbc
news chief it has to be chief
chief um playoff analytics
correspondent analyst playoff analyst
okay analytics
i like that you're saying chief and not
senior because i feel senior is the one
they give you when you're kind of
retirement age
sure i'll take chief over senior yes
senior senior
or okay chief uh playoff
lord of the board lord of the board
right analyst
right i i think you were under something
there was sort of analytics
correspondence how about analytics
analyst
i like it that's you know for for some
people who talk fast that could be dicey
but we'll we'll we'll figure that out
um a few more minutes left here with
steve kornacki here
on the rich eisen show okay um you know
um sports is all about rivalries right
steve
you know it's about uh somebody raising
their game and their game is
always compared to somebody else's game
do you and john king have a rivalry
steve is there a rivalry there it's
funny i
i actually i don't think we've ever
actually met um
you know it's probably one of those
things where you've been in the same
room at some kind of uh
you know a function or something or an
event i don't think we've ever met he's
a he's from massachusetts too he's from
dorchester um i i
will go out in a limb and say he's
probably a pats fan too so i'd say we're
kinda on the same team there
okay but when it comes to big board
material i mean is there
you know would there be some sort of
flex here like you know
i know you know i don't want to get i
don't want to get drawn into anything i
know i truly respect what he does
i really do and and he's been doing it
um
you know for a while now and it's i i
don't get a chance and i think this is
probably true for him too yes the way
these election nights go
i i never get a chance to see what
anybody else is doing you know i i don't
get this of course you know he's doing i
don't get to see what fox is doing
i'm sure that's true for him um but
before you know i've been doing
elections since 2014 before i started
doing elections in 2014
i would i certainly saw king then and i
i i truly truly have nothing but respect
neither do so do i steve and again it's
a as a
somebody who does live television for a
living it is truly remarkable what you
did on election night and have been
doing on election night and i did you
know on occasion flip around i did see
what john did
i will tell you this steve i don't know
if john king could do his
uh math like you you can do on on live
television i think he got him
on just doing subtraction certainly five
figure subtractions
in your head you did that if i'm not
mistaken this past election
it's funny i i computational math adding
and subtracting
yes for some reason i've always been
really good at it but i my math skills
do not go any farther than that i was
like the world's worst calculus student
growing up trigonometry
um i was terrible at it but i could do
computational math so it finally came in
handy
oh my gosh yeah i think you subtracted
five figures from five figures and you
carried ones and
all that stuff in your head and you
nailed it down before they actually
computer actually updated it on your
board i watched that on live television
and i rewound i rewound it steve and
showed it to my children
to say this is why seriously steve
they're 12
nine and seven i'm like this is why math
is important right here
i showed that i thought it is it's
something i
i um developed kind of at a young age
and it just stayed with me and there you
go i got to use it on national tv
okay last couple of minutes steve i'm
going to ask you the question you get
asked all the time it's
it's it's a different audience here uh
add up all the pants that you have the
khaki pants that you have
the total would be what what's the total
number of pants that you have steve i
don't ask this of normal people
of as a normal question
certainly single digits okay i'm gonna
say five i think five is probably the
answer
all the same color what do you got is it
all the same i got four that are this
like uh
the color i had last night i got four
that are like that okay and i got
one that's a slightly lighter shade okay
how do you choose
how do you how do you choose what's uh
what's worthy of nbc sports and nmsnbc
or
how do what's the choice process can you
use whatever is clean
um but there seemed to be a reaction to
the
the ones i wore last night seemed to get
a reaction election week i i have no
idea why but they seem to
so i figured kind of last night i was
talking to the nbc guys and i was like
uh
you know do you have is there a wardrobe
thing here you know do you want me to
wear anything in particular and they
just said no just do
what you did for the election so i was
like okay well that takes the pressure
off i've got you covered there i mean
that would be like
to use the the uh the uh analogy that
you will definitely get
being a a patriot fan it's kind of like
seeing when belichick shows up to a
press conference in a full suit and tie
it's
jarring like wait a minute does he
actually wear a suit like ever
and then so if you showed up um in in a
suit
uh it would just be weird i'll be honest
with you yeah
i i like that if this means i've gotten
myself off the hook for the rest of my
life from really having to get dressed
up i'll take that
okay uh i have uh two last ones for you
steve and i appreciate you calling in
i'm sure you've been pulled in many
different directions here
um two last ones for you here uh
did you think ever well i guess let's
put it this way
what's the if i came up to you and say
september
okay september and say by the end of the
year you will be
on nbc sports halftime breaking down
the playoff probabilities on sunday
night football
as a halftime correspondent or you would
be named by people magazine is one of
the sexiest men alive which one would
you say is even crazy
which one's the crazy the second one is
the craziest one and you want to talk
about where
where there might be vote fraud and
where there might be tabulation errors i
think
whoever uh whoever added that up for
that people magazine thing there i don't
know how i got on that list
i tell people they got the alive part
right are you saying that
the the the dominion voting system was
used for by people magazine
that might be the place to look the
people magazine voting because i i
all right so then let me top it all uh
last one for you here
this would this would be look uh a
career choice
but it would also be something greatly
appreciated by me
um here on the rich eisen show we don't
understand why
in the playoff formats that you see of
the teams on the screen that are
division leaders or in one column as you
know and then the wild card leaders are
in
another column and then the teams on the
outside looking in are in a third column
i don't know who came up with the phrase
that's always used by everybody as
in the hunt i don't understand why
they're it that
every single network uses that except
for this show we use the phrase
sniffing it okay
the it being the playoffs they're
sniffing it if you could drop
if you do this again on sunday night
football the phrase sniffing it
instead of in the hunt or on the outside
looking in that would mean the world to
me
and uh again i'm i guess that means i'm
a shell of a man but
would you consider it steve to do that
let me let me see what i can do
let me see if i can uh if i can uh uh uh
get that into my uh
muscle memory for next week okay or
sometime in the next couple weeks
i like doing favors rich okay steve
that's not a no
right chris we didn't hear a no it
didn't say not a no that's not a no
no no we'll say okay so i will be on the
edge of my seat as you break down these
big boards
uh like they are on election night um to
hear the words sniffing it for teams
that are on the outside looking in like
the arizona cardinals right now they're
they're sniffing it at this hour they're
sniffing it that's all i need to hear
that's it i'm i'm gonna you know it's
one of those things too i want to run it
by a few people to make sure there's
good
there's no no no no no no
i'm in my 25th year of broadcasting uh
of of forgiveness rather than permission
and uh i'm telling you you're in good
shape steve you're in good shape so just
give it a whirl it's basically what i'm
saying all right
i'll i'll think about that one thanks
for the call steve it was a delight to
see you in this role last night and
uh a home run uh to use the phrase from
a different sport just great so thanks
for the call
thanks so much rich appreciate it steve
kornacki right here the uh nbc sports
chief playoff analyst analytics
analyst yes nbc sports
chief playoffs analytics analyst
cpa there you go
steve that was awesome that was so much
fun that was
nice and i learned it and they and and
the producing
look you know nbc sports uh rob hyland's
crew
doing it they had the board set up where
he also could change the board
he could move it around and circle it
and do his thing
it's what do you want do his thing
addressing the camera
and it was great he stuck the landing
start of today and at this hour at this
hour
arizona 52 chance by pro football falcon
focus to make the playoffs
they san francisco and chicago currently
sniffing it
if i hear steve kornacki say that maybe
rip the knob
off we'll we'll do all we can do that'll
be like a costanza moment
what more do we have to accomplish at
least i made him laugh with sniffing it
that's it
even if he doesn't say it but you can't
ask permission you just can't
what's he going to do by the way brian
williams would say go for it
i know that for sure brian williams
would say go for it
i mean it's live tv what are they going
to do yeah what are they going to do
it just comes out what was that all
about
i was going to say is rich eisen said to
do it and then i'll i'll say
uh please forgive me thank you
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here